Today's guest is Gary 10.
He is a designer engineer and founder turned early stage
investor. Co-founding initialized capital with Alexis Ohanian.
In 2013,
their firm manages over $500 million.
And if invested at the earliest stages of companies like Coinbase,
Flexport, Instacart, and Cruz prior to initialize,
Gary spent nearly five years as a partner at Y Combinator
advising and funding more than 1000 companies and founders
before YC. He was a co-founder of a blog platform called [inaudible],
which was acquired by Twitter in 2012, for $20 million.
He then worked at Palentier as a founding member of the engineering team and
fun fact, he actually designed the Pelletiers logo.
Gary also holds a bachelor in computer systems engineering from
Stanford university. Wow. That is one heck of a resume. Very impressive.
But I got very lucky by getting in on that's.
What everyone says. And here he is talking to me a YouTuber,
the camera of the camera, unless you want to do a little bit of promo, but yeah,
so,
and I also heard that now you're the portfolio initialized portfolio is valued
that 36 billion.
Correct. And in almost every single case,
we were the first or among the first check. So when the company was worth,
certainly under $10 million and we funded about 200 companies.
So like Coinbase, you were one of the first. Yeah, that is crazy.
So I have a lot of viewers, most of them are from a high school or like college,
just, um, just a little curiosity. Did you do well in high school and college.
Uh, high school I aimed for exactly perfect a minuses.
Cause I figured out that my, our college admissions process,
the transcript that the district would send out didn't have plus or minus.
And so every moment I spent on getting a plus or not minus meant that
it wasn't optimized. Wow.
Okay. That's a very 80 20 mindset. That's cool. You got a min-max of your life.
That's true. That's true. That's true.
And then what did you do with the other time?
Because I'm pretty sure you had more time because you didn't optimize for eight.
Oh man. I mean the reality is I actually grew,
grew up pretty poor in Fremont or Fremont. Yeah.
And so we were growing up in apartments. I wanted my parents to buy a house.
I mean,
I wanted to grow up in the house and I was 14 and I was obsessed with
computers and I knew how to make webpages.
So I opened up the internet section of the yellow pages and cold called until
someone gave me a job for seven bucks an hour to make websites for cities.
And that was my first job when I was 14.
I ended up taking all those earnings over every summer and winter break for a
few years.
And we ended up putting down the down payment for the home that me and my
brother grew up in. So that's amazing.
And so me computers just fundamentally changed my life.
Like I grew up like sometimes food insecure.
Like I know what it means to be hungry or show up to school,
like wearing the same clothes again, you know? Um,
and so computers actually really changed my life in a fundamental way.
And I would've worked on computers for free, but it turns out,
especially over the past 20 years, it's basically like winning a lot,
like winning the lottery was being into computers like now and in the past.
20 Years. Yeah. I do feel very fortunate that I chose computer science for sure.
You know, it's funny. Cause I,
I used to work when I was maybe not 14 because that was illegal.
But when I was 15, I think I worked at McDonald's yeah. The contrast here,
but yeah.
And um, my dad thought I would got really soft by just working on computers.
He was like, maybe you should go work at McDonald's. I was like, no dad.
Computers. That's really cool. So back to, you know, now what you're doing,
you're a VC right. Initialized capital. And um, can I ask you,
what kind of companies do you guys invest in or what do you look for?
Yeah, totally. Uh, we are super focused on the earliest stage. Okay.
And then, so, you know, people with just an idea,
when we met Brian Armstrong who created Coinbase, he just quit his job, uh,
as head of anti-fraud for Airbnb and Airbnb had just been minted as a billion
dollar company. And now it's worth like North of 30 billion, which is crazy,
but for him to quit that job at that moment, uh,
and work on the super speculative thing called Bitcoin,
that was really noteworthy for us. I think it was 2013.
13. That's crazy. Okay. And then you,
you guys were one of the first invest in them or you were to first invest.
Yeah. I mean we funded them at Y Combinator and then initialized.
I was able to invest again. So that's one of the funnest things,
seeing people who are just have this crazy idea. I mean,
Bitcoin was fringe, you know,
I read about it on hacker news and dismissed it like a lot of other people.
But for us, it goes back to the founders.
Like if they are really smart and really great engineers who can build
anything, that's the most important thing.
And this is in contrast to how I think most venture capitalists work.
Most people just look at the buzzword, they look at the resume,
they look at the buzzwords and they say, check, check, check, okay,
I'm going to take that meeting or not.
And I think that that's why startups suck so bad.
That's why you read about you open up tech crimes or you open up Twitter and you
read about the startup, the raise $10 million. It's like,
that doesn't sound very good at all.
And it's because a lot of startup investors don't think from first principles,
they're never built a company before, or they never built software before.
Like they don't know how to be an engineer.
They don't know how to be a designer. They've never built anything.
And so what do you, do you rely on your PowerPoint watching skills, I guess.
So aside from technical skills or you know,
what they can and cannot in terms of personality traits,
what do you look for in these founders?
The number one thing I think is actually grit around
iteration.
So I mean just making something that people actually want and then putting it
out there, even if it sucks. If,
if there's one person out there in the world who would be happy that that
exists, then you did the right thing, right?
If you are putting out software that you're not embarrassed about,
then you waited too long generally. Um, and then once you have that out there,
like you don't have to blast the world,
but get like at least one or two people using it and relying on it.
And if you can get one or two people to really love it,
then that's the kernel of something that could grow a lot faster.
And so that's one thing that we ask ourselves a lot. When we meet a founder,
have they made something that, uh,
their customers actually truly love because that's more important than
all the Stanford and Harvard's and all the Google and Facebook, you know,
resumes in the world. Like you could take all of those and add them up.
And it wouldn't matter if those people can't sit down in front of a user,
figure out what they need and then build the thing and then have someone be
really happy that that exists. So it's simple. It's I actually shockingly.
Simple. So it sounds simple, but I mean obviously finding product, product,
market fit is not always easy, right?
Like that's actually like the biggest thing.
So imagine if I did find a product market fit, how would I pitch it to you?
How can you extract the most signal out of my pitch?
Or how should I make my pitch so that you can extract it? Yeah.
Totally. Number one thing is, uh, and I get cold.
I get probably 20 cold emails every single day, which is crazy. Um,
and these are actually not actionable for me because in that email I can
actually tell, uh, what is it, who's it for?
What problem does it solve? And then how do I even know if it's actually solved?
Well, those are sort of the four things. Really. It's not a lot of things,
but you know, if someone was going to call email near cold,
pitch me or pitch anything to any investor,
that would be how I advise it.
And that's sort of the process that a founder has to take every single
day, whether it's not just for investors, it's actually to your customer,
to like, cause a customer is sitting there and you know,
I'm trying to buy Bitcoin. It's a huge pain in the butt.
I have to go to this other website. I have to go to Western union.
I think I went to Western union really.
And I wired money from Western union cash to some
random address in India maybe or something like that.
And then it magically appeared in this super sketchy payment system that then
showed up on Mt. Gox and I could buy my first Bitcoin.
And so that was the state of affairs, you know, today, uh,
everyone forgets because Coinbase now exists. You go to the website,
you put in your credit card, you put in your bank account information,
it's trusted, it's encrypted, it's all in the United States.
It's fully compliant. It's frankly,
way better than what the alternative. I mean,
it sounds simple and it is very hard to actually find a problem like that and B
solve it in exactly that way.
[Inaudible]. So now that you've invested in multiple startups,
I'm sure some of the startups film, right? Not all of them succeeding.
Probably more than 50% not working out.
Why do you think startups fail?
What are the most common issues or problems that make them fail?
Yeah, the number one, um,
really early ends up being co-founder problems actually. Um,
especially when you're only two or three people, uh,
you actually kind of need those people.
And so that's probably the number one thing.
And that's why when we look for teams that are starting out,
we really like teams that have actually worked together before,
or have known each other for a really long time. I mean,
one litmus test almost for whether or not a co-founder is good.
Is have you ever been camping in a storm because that's kind of how
it's going to feel like it's going to be garbage.
Like you're going to get punched in the face. It's going to be wet.
It's going to be cold. Like someone forgot, matches.
There's going to be like a thousand problems that crop up.
And if you are able to work with someone,
you can get through all those problems and, and you know,
the thing is that's going to happen. So.
What about solo founders? Have you ever invested in solo founder?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, the classic advice was try and find co-founders,
but solo founders can make it work too. Um,
either they have to build the whole first version themselves, uh,
and they have to raise money or, you know, there are lots of different paths.
Um, it's usually better to be a solo founder, uh,
than to have co-founders who are.
Bad sense that makes it bad for each other.
Yeah. Bad for each other. Cause you know, it's almost certain death when you're,
you know, out there,
maybe you're trying to raise money and then you lose a co-founder.
Yeah. I think I read an initialized capital. You said something about, if,
if we have you as an investor,
then you're going to help us prevent the 1009 lines that potential,
what are those a thousand landmines?
And we could probably talk for hours about it. Um,
just like we can do a few more, um, aside from co-founder stuff, honestly,
a lot of it is shipping.
So a lot of people are so obsessed with getting it perfect
that they actually never ship.
And there are lots of examples of companies that have actually raised millions
of dollars hired tens of people worked on problems for years and then never
shipped sometimes when they finally do ship.
It's so late that the opportunity for them was a year and a half ago,
competitors, you know, came and went startup entire competitors,
started released and died and it's just too late. And you know,
they burned millions of dollars. I, you know, it's crazy that that happens,
but it happens a lot actually.
So being able to iterate in front of users really important,
and there are startups even today that have not shipped yet. And the.
I see, I see. So if I am a startup founder,
like why would I come to you for money rather than other people imagine how that
rock solid product. Right.
So why would I come to initialize capital versus another? Yeah.
See from, well, we started companies before.
So part of it is so many investors have never started anything.
And so they're very lean back and you know,
if you've ever done pitches,
you can kind of tell what kind of pitch is going to be immediately because it
kind of feels like you're being watched by your teachers from high school or
something. It's, you know, it's lean back. There's not a lot of, you know,
sort of discussion. There's no back and forth. It's just impressed me.
And then I'm going to grade you. Um,
and those aren't the P those aren't the investors you want.
And then what's worse is after that, those investors will say, well,
I'm interested. This is very interesting. But, uh,
come back to me when you have a lead,
which is basically the,
it's just literally the worst thing that investors do and it's,
and most of them do it. It's completely crazy. What do you mean by lead? Oh, um,
who is going to do most of the money into the round?
Oh, got it. Got it. Okay. So a lot of people,
if they just want to back kind of like.
That's the thing, there's basically two types of investors.
From what I can tell, there are people who have eyes and they can see,
it's like, Oh, that's fire. Right. I'm going to invest.
I don't care if anyone else investing. In fact,
I hope nobody does because I want to invest as much as I can.
So we're that type of investor. And then there's a giant,
there's probably 10 times more, uh,
in number and dollar amount in follower capital.
So these are people who have never built anything before,
or they're purely finance people and they are actually waiting for
outside signal. Right. These are the people who love the checkmarks.
These are people who are not believers. Right.
Yeah. I guess in their defense,
that's a perfectly valid strategy for what they have, right? Yeah.
Like you still have money and that's it. Exactly. So that's perfectly valid.
It's kind of like, um, I guess, stock investing.
Some people see if there's trending then. Okay. Then let's yeah.
Get up. So for us, we'll say yes. And we'll fund you right away or we'll say no,
and we'll tell you why, and that's rare on its own. And then after that,
we're actually gonna work with the founder to actually, you know,
I'll close candidates, we have monthly strategy sessions, you know,
basically I'll meet with founders as often as they possibly want to. Um,
our usually cadence usually it's, um, you know,
every month or so and whatever problem that's happening with the business,
we basically try and address it. Um, and you know, definitely not in a way that,
you know, I'm not their boss.
I'm basically just another founder who is trying to help. Right.
And that's actually really valuable.
So you don't have much say into the direction of their company. Right.
But you can influence them and help them.
Um, in our experience after funding, lots of people, if we need control,
we funded the wrong company. I mean, we want to find companies.
We want to find founders who they have a clear sense of their direction.
And honestly, any investor,
any advisor is only going to spend what an hour,
two hours per week at most thinking about this problem as a founder,
the founder is thinking about this, like 24 seven, you know,
even when they're sleeping, they're thinking about the problems that they have.
So I have no right to come and say, here's how you should run your day.
I guess,
last question about startups for people who want to start their own startup,
either they're already in high or they're late high school, college,
or even full-timers now,
what advice would you give them if they want to do a startup?
I guess the number one thing is pick a problem that's around them that they
understand. So the hardest thing about, um,
students starting startups is they haven't experienced enough of life.
And a lot of the biggest problems that exist in, uh, you know,
sort of humanity today that could be addressed by startups. Um,
they actually require a lot of weird specialized knowledge, right. Um,
and so often I ask them like, well, what's weird about you. Like,
what's weird about your family. What's weird about, you know,
what your dad does. Like what, you know, sometimes,
sometimes people grow up around like, you know,
shipping and freight and then they go on to actually start something in that
space. Like the, you know,
the weirder and the more unusual that is often that is someplace to actually
start, uh, because you know, companies like Flexport are exactly that it's,
you know, there's an entire world of people who care about how, uh,
shipping containers move around the world. And then on the flip side,
there's sort of smart engineers.
Like people like you watching who are really smart,
who can build any kind of software and what you basically need is this Venn
diagram to meet in the middle and, um, where that needs,
that's where a billion-dollar startup could be. Right.
So you need to know something weird and special and different than, you know,
everyone else who's agreed.
And engineer. Yeah. That's awesome. Yeah.
Like try to find inefficiencies in the world,
especially if it affects you personally.
Cause then you understand the problem very well. Yeah, totally.
And then apply technology to it.
And then usually that's a pretty good combination for a successful startup.
Right. Totally. Awesome. All right.
We'll take a break here and then we'll talk about VCs.
All right.